you guys Fame cricket here they are the
Fame cricket let's watch something
cricket don't like what is it with what
is with the English and cricket it's a
sport it's like saying what's with the
Americans in baseball I know but like
I'm not talking [ __ ] about cricket I'm
just curious about cricket and like the
history of it I don't think about it and
like it's an English sport and then they
exported it to rest of the world near
the rest of the world beats them out it
I know it's really big in India yeah
it's big in any of the big Australia big
in like South Africa I mean clearly some
what it was before baseball right okay
cricket was before baseball yeah I
imagine is some sort of like lineage
there with ya has to be I mean you hit
the stumps you hit the hit the Black Sea
where the rules like okay that little
that that wicked thing or that two of
them cd's weren't there when it hits
that yet so he's the guys picked the
picture or bowler bullet probably for
doing this and he's trying to hit the
stumps okay to get that guy out it's
like getting three strikes and one so if
he hits it guys out the guy no but note
at the batter is that what they call if
they're called the end of whatever let's
say that batter if he hits it he's gonna
try and run between the two wickets any
every tiny ones it's a point got it okay
okay she runs back and forth between the
two but it's also like home wrong thing
where if he hits it and they're not
doing the background catches that
without advancing he's all she's out
okay somebody else for a woman you're
gone want me how many outs into the
other know like 10 buck 10 buck otters
quest always said oh he's out hit the
wickets he hit the wickets he hit the
wickets nice did he he did yesterday the
[ __ ] off so you're out [ __ ] sorry
alright let's go see the Queen
you